Sure,
pictures they make these days roll into
TV.
Cut,
cut,
cut.
The opening shot of a touch of evil was
six and a half minutes long.
Three or four in a way,
set up the whole picture of the one
track.
Father was a key grip and what about
absolute beginners?
That was an extraordinary shocked.
The hell is that I've never heard of it.
Now you see it aren't long.
Takes awesome.
I'm talking about the huge ones,
the masterpieces where all the technical
camera work,
special effects and carefully
choreographed movement pushes the
boundaries of cinema as an art form and
leaves us thinking,
Holy Shit.
If you want to read more about how
awesome they are,
I recommend that these three articles or
even these tech.
How about 25?
What I'm saying is we're all well aware
of how long it takes work.
They dazzled,
they entertain,
they pushed film to its limits,
but I want to make a quick video essay
that explores one way long takes might
people limited in their storytelling
abilities to start.
Let's hear from someone familiar who
doesn't like long takes.
Don't know why I really dialed in the
stump.
I can only call it a stunt
it.
Rope rope was hitchcock's attempt at a
movie taking place in real time in one
long take.
Originally a play.
Hitchcock kept every action and reaction
in the frame and let the camera roll.
Cameras at the time could only film 20
minutes per reel,
so we had to hide cuts in between scenes
when he needed to.
What are you worrying about,
Philip?
After all the result is something
hitchcock didn't think was all that
great.
He comments on what it was missing in a
French interview with the truffaut,
which explains the French translator in
the background.
When I look back of it was
quite nonsense.
Memorials,
Joe Bosco.
I was breaking all my own simplicity to
of film.
The Samuel just fill me in on the
cutting of film to tell the story.
A lot of people think the cotton is St
Montage or assembly is taking a man from
one place,
Jordan Adler and jumping into a closeup
of him which griffith invented.
It's true,
but
to me it goes much deeper.
So that's what long takes.
Can Miss Editing.
In many ways,
hitchcock was simply filming a play,
but if it was something originally a
play,
you can use editing to tell a story and
hitchcock things.
Editing is a strong storytelling device
that was missing with his movie.
How could rope have used editing to tell
its story?
12,
angry men originally a teleplay and then
a stage play also has a limited set and
heavy dialogue,
but the editing tells us everything.
I'm like rope,
which has no Arabic.
The beginning shots are wide
uncomfortable.
There's actually a six minute long take
in the beginning where conversation is
light and everyone looks at ease in the
early scenes,
most of the dialogue features multiple
people that takes are relatively long
and shots of single people aren't too
close as the movie progresses.
Intense scenes have super close ups of
characters and the are much quicker by
allowing the camera to cut quickly from
closeup too.
Closeup editing showcases the intensity
of this
seat
guilty not to mention the Erie overhead
lighting,
the performances and the rain in the
background.
The cuts are very important here too
quickly and efficiently.
Move from the action to the reaction as
opposed to a long take where the camera
has to either whip around or we see
action and reaction at the same time,
which gives them both equal weight to
the viewer,
but that's not to say filmmakers can't
direct our eyes without using cuts.
On the contrary,
director's guide our eyes with the right
lighting,
camera,
movement and frame composition.
The University of Edinburg developed a
visual tools that track eye movement so
they can show people a movie clip and
track what they look at in this scene in
there will be blood.
The person talking is important to the
viewer according to where they're
looking,
but I movement also shifts when someone
moves to smoke a cigarette or starts
leaving the frame.
There's lots of ways to direct the eye
like what's in focus where everybody is
looking lights and geometry.
You may not notice it consciously,
but directors are telling you where to
look,
especially in flashy long takes.
The long battle scene in the revenue is
chaos,
but it's directed chaos.
You look from one person to another or
at that specific era whizzing past the
camera,
but according to hitchcock along take,
just can't beat the intensity,
speed and storytelling power of an
effective cut.
Copping
five.
It really should be called a hem.
When clips are assembled together
through editing,
they create a new story for the viewer.
If you cut from one clip to another,
your mind associates the clips with each
other and creates the idea.
Of course,
the classic example is the psycho shower
scene,
but it works in a variety of movies in
the Godfather.
Coppola cuts from the spiritual
cleansing of Michael's son through
baptism to the violent cleansing of
mafia leaders.
One cleanses with holy water.
The other one
blood.
You could write a book on what this
editing choice means in the context of
the film,
but one thing is very clear.
The editing is what establishes this
symbolic connection and a take just
doesn't have the ability to
automatically associate two different
ideas in a way as effective as these
edits.
I mean the
film which moved in rapid succession for
the.
I create an idea
I love long takes,
anybody can appreciate them for how
beautiful they are,
but they are limited in their
storytelling power.
They give us more choices in what to
look at compared to cutting from face to
face or object to object.
This has its advantages with more to
look at.
We can be more overwhelmed,
more taking it back,
more amazed,
but a cut forcing us to look at one
thing that can be intense and has the
kind of emphasis a big shot doesn't
have.
Sometimes an edit works,
sometimes a long take works.
It just depends on how you look at it.
Of course,
a difference,
how long it takes.
Supposedly we do it in five minutes,
so what?
Let's take an hour ballgame doesn't
start till 8:00.
If you wish,
this video was longer,
you're in luck because all time movies
has a great video that focuses on how
directors pull off these intricate long
takes and sometimes long takes are
hidden in plain sight.
Watch Tony [inaudible] video on the
Spielberg one or to learn more about
that.
Both these videos are in the
description.
Thanks for watching.